hello and welcome so I'm going to talk
about measure preserving extended
Dynamic mode decomposition or if you
like a four line algorithm for structure
preserving and convergent DMD
so I'm interested in a dynamical system
with a state X inside some State space
Omega this is governed by an unknown
function f so the state of time n plus 1
is given by F of the state at time n a
discrete time dynamical system
I could also consider continuous time
dynamical systems by looking at discrete
time steps
now my goal is to learn properties of
the system from trajectory data
collected in snapshots so this will be X
in blue and Y in green where Y is equal
to f of x
this data could be collected from a
single long trajectory or multiple
shorter bursts it could come from
experimental measurements or numerical
simulations and I can use it for things
like forecasting control design or
simply understanding this dynamical
system
so that's the goal we're going to
approach this using Koopman operators so
the cumin operator K acts on functions
on the state space Omega via this
composition formula here
so the cumin operator looks one time
step forward
this composition allows you to show that
the equipment operator is linear so
you've gone from a non-linear
representation in state space to a
linear representation in function space
and the koopment operator allows you to
map between the two so this looks great
right you've gone from something
nonlinear to something linear but there
is a catch the cumin operator acts on an
infinite dimensional function space so
you've gone from non-linear finite
dimensional to linear but infinite
dimensional
right throughout this talk we are going
to make an assumption
that the system is measure preserving
with respect to a volume or measure
Omega this allows us to work in an L2
space so space of square integrable
functions
but the key thing is that there's an
inner product structure these angled
brackets and this will be key
so many systems have a measure they
preserve for example hamiltonian eggotic
or many systems in their post-transit
regimes
but the key equation to remember is that
having a a measure preserving system
means that the cumin operator preserves
the inner product
so the inner product between two uh well
between an observable Gene itself is the
same
as between K G and kg
okay so so why is the equipment operator
useful well
you have something called the kuma mode
decomposition which allows you to split
up a an observable G in terms of a sum
of eigenfunctions whose coefficients are
known as Kuma modes and something that
I've labeled as the continuous Spectrum
or an integral over generalized eigen
functions a good analogy is if you place
a white light through a prism split it
up into different wavelengths here we're
splitting up G into a bunch of simpler
parts and we'll see in a second that we
know how each of these parts behaves
under the Dynamics that allows us to
place things together those simpler
Parts together to get an idea of the
whole in a similar way you might look at
the intensity in different wavelengths
of solar radiation and this allows you
to deduce the chemical composition of
the Sun
right so if you want to evaluate G at
time n this is the same thing as
applying the equipment operator n times
2G now you know how the common operator
pays for eigenfunctions you bring up
this power of the eigenvalue in a
similar fashion you get this Fourier
integral over the continuous Spectrum so
this is an example of where it's looking
at the simpler Parts allows you to build
up the more complicated Parts more
generally the spectral information
of the cumin operator encodes geometric
features invariant measures transient
and long-time Behavior care instructions
cause your periodicity
Etc
so our goal
now becomes data-driven approximation of
the spectral properties of the Koopman
operator k
there are some challenges associated
with this goal
number one how do we compute the
Spectrum we want a method that converges
how do we deal with continuous Spectrum
so this component over here our
continuous spectrum is associated with
chaotic systems normally but it also
appears in non-chaotic systems for
example the pendulum which we'll look at
later on
the nonlinear pendulum
um
the third challenge is can we can we
achieve those goals
with a discretization that preserves the
measure Omega so this is very important
for things like stability improved
qualitative and long-time Behavior
looking at things like long-time
statistics autocorrelations and things
like that
so those are the challenges and what I'm
going to show you is a four line
algorithm
that tackles these challenges very
simply for DMD type methods so to build
this approach
our first step is extended Dynamic mode
decomposition or edmd I'm going to offer
two interpretations of this algorithm
the first is shown here
so we have a Subspace of observables PSI
1 up to psi n this gives us features
which I've collected in this quasimatrix
PSI
and we have
two types of data matrices psyx in blue
here which is just the features
evaluated at The X points and PSI Y
which is the features evaluated the Y
points in green we also have a diagonal
weight Matrix which just tells us how
important each of the snapshot data is
now you can interpret edmd
as taking these matrices which you get
from the data and using them as a
quadrature
or an approximation of certain inner
products here so we have this Matrix G
PSI x w PSI X or blue blue this gives
you an approximation of the inner
products between the observables
themselves you also have this Matrix a
or PSI x w PSI Y which gives you the
same inner products but now you've got
an additional K here on the left
observable
using these two matrices you can build
up an approximation of the koopment
operator
on the Subspace corresponding to the
span of these n observables so that's
the first interpretation
the key point being these approximations
of inner products the second
interpretation
which is probably more familiar is
minimizing a certain residual
so if we take an observable G which we
can expand in our
PSI one of the Cyan are observables like
this we can look at the error of
approximating the coupon operator acting
on G
by a matrix that acts on the
coefficients these coefficients in bold
face
it's very natural to try and minimize
the square of this error integrated over
the state space Omega so that leads to
this minimization problem here again if
we interpret the snapshot data as giving
a quadrature for this quadrature rule
for this integral we end up with the
following a weighted least squares
problem
okay so that's uh in fact the original
way that edmd was was derived so you
have this weighted least squares problem
now combining these two interpretations
remember the inner products and this
weighted least squares problem allows us
to derive a method that preserves the
measure to see this
recall that measure preserving means
that the Kumon operator preserves this
inner product
we can approximate these inner products
using the Matrix capital G the so very
very simple idea is to enforce
this equality here between capital G and
K star that's the adjoints g k
you do this you end up with exactly the
same minimization problem
but with this additional constraint
you apply quadrature as before and this
leads to something called an orthogonal
procrustis problem
okay so it's the same uh problem but now
with this extra condition okay this
assumption here
all right so so this leads to a very
simple algorithm we know how to solve
this minimization problem here it is
four lines in the first line we compute
The Matrix of the matrices G and a using
the snapshot data in the second line we
compute a singular value decomposition
of this Matrix set so this is the
inverse of the square root of G
we then take that singular value
decomposition we throw away the Matrix
corresponding to the singular values and
we swap
the order of the unitary parts and we
compute an eigen decomposition in step
three
then in step four we can piece all of
these parts together and obtain an
approximation of the equipment operator
this Matrix K it's eigenvectors V and
its eigenvalues Lambda so it's a very
simple approach and you can see that you
can use it with any DMD type method for
example standard DMD is a special case
of edmd so you can still use this
algorithm for DMD approaches where of
course the DMD the observables become
linear functions
okay so let's look at an example of this
in practice so here I've collected data
I've got a jet and I've also got a plate
okay so there's some turbulent flow over
here in my field of view I collect
um approximately uh 50 000 data points
or or locations in in the physical
domain of the vertical and horizontal
velocity okay so that gives me the
dimension of the diamical system
approximately one hundred thousand the
Reynolds number of this flow is about
six times ten to the four
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show the prediction of the turbulent
kinetic energy using the Koopman mode
decomposition with three algorithms in
green I have MP edmd the new algorithm
measured preserving extended Dynamite
decomposition and you can see that it
does a really good job of predicting the
correct energy value
in blue I also have a pi DMD it's a
beautiful algorithm you can look at it
in this paper down here the pi stands
for physics informed so Pi DMD is um
trying to preserve the measure but it
doesn't use that Matrix G those inner
products and that's really a crucial
difference so you see that Pi DMD is
stable so this blue curve here but
predicts the wrong energy value if we
look at edmd
in red we see that it's unstable as time
progresses
okay so you can really see the
difference if you look at the time
average kinetic energy against the
height the height y here is how how far
up I look above the plate in this field
of view
so MP edmd the new algorithm in green is
able to get the correct distribution of
energy
Pi DMD is stable but gives you the wrong
distribution of the energy
we can also look at the uh the actual um
flow predicted using the kuma Modi
composition
okay so remember the system is chaotic
so we don't expect to reproduce the flow
exactly
but MP edmd is doing a really good job
of getting the correct features
Pi DMD is stable but is clearly
producing the wrong type of flow
edmd you'll see as time progresses
initially does a good job but then
starts to blow up it becomes uh unstable
and that's really because it's not
preserving the measure the measure
preservation of
um
mpedmd is giving you a stability
property
okay
so that's one example you can also take
this example and look at
wave number Spectra which roughly
speaking are Fourier transforms of
autocorrelations
and these give you an idea of the
turbulent statistics of the flow so here
are the the true statistics here's the
statistics um produced using
trajectories of MP edmd it's very hard
to Spot the Difference here
if you look at Pi DMD
it gives you something that's stable but
it's got the wrong statistics and
particularly you've got this band at the
wrong frequency edmd is giving you an
unstable prediction right you can see
this in the lower frequencies
so a summary of the Convergence Theory
you can consult the paper to look at the
theorems and also the proofs but in a
nutshell using this idea of preserving
the measure or structure preservation
you're able to prove all sorts of nice
properties about the algorithm MP edmd
for example you have
convergent Spectra okay so it's the
first go lurkin method that achieves
this you have convergent spectral
measures so those are a way to deal with
continuous Spectra if you want details
and then consult the paper you also have
a convergent Kumon mode decomposition
and finally your measure preserving even
if your data is not collected in an
orthogonal basis and the key ingredient
for proving all of these nice properties
hold for MP edmd is that you have a
measure preserving discretization
for example let's look at the Lorenz
system so here I'm going to show you
convergence of spectral measures or
continuous Spectra so The Observers I'm
going to look at are the three
um coordinates in X X1 X2 X3 I'm going
to look at
observables corresponding to delay
embedding okay so g k acting on G up to
K to the N minus 1 acting on G delay
embedding is really nice because MPE DMD
allows you to give an explicit
convergence rate so you know that the
error associated with using this space
of observables is going to Decay like
log n over n
okay so here's the convergence in the
number of data points for G1 G2 and G3
the measures or the continuous Spectra
you see the convergence at the expected
Monte Carlo rate over here you have
convergence in the number of delays or
the N here and this is giving you the
expected rate of convergence so that's
very nice
let's also look at the non-linear the
fully nonlinear pendulum okay so this
system of equations here here the state
space
is this periodic interval corresponding
to the angle X1 and also the whole of
the real line corresponding to the
momentum
I'm going to look at observables
corresponding to delay embedding of this
observable G
now if I look at the generalized
eigenfunctions or continuous spectrum of
the kubern operator associated with the
system what I should get is a bunch of
the racks
localized along constant energy surfaces
in Phase space
so here I've plotted the eigenfunctions
computed using MP edmd and edmd and you
can see this localization okay so this
log is on a log scale log of the
absolute value you also see that the MP
edmd eigenvalue or eigenfunction
is much more localized than the edmd one
okay and you expect localization so this
is an indication that MP edmd is more
accurate okay so let's make that more
precise we can measure the error so I'm
going to also add gaussian random noise
to the measurement matrices PSI X and
PSI y I'm going to measure the mean
error of the eigen vectors and the
eigenvalues
by error I'm Computing the error
Associated to the true infinite
dimensional equipment operator without
any measurement noise to do that I can
use something called resdmd which is
discussed in these papers here but for
now all you should think about is that
this is just a way of measuring the
error associated with the infinite
dimensional function space
okay so I have the error the mean error
plotted against the noise ratio for
different M number of measurements and
you see that MP edmd is pre-stable with
respect to noise and the error decreases
as we increase the number of
measurements this is known as strongly
consistent estimation in contrast for
edmd it's much more unstable with
respect to noise and the error doesn't
decrease as we increase the number of
measurements
so why does this occur why is MP edmd
more robust to noise
well it turns out that the orthogonal
procrustis problem is equivalent to a
constrained total least squares problem
so totally squares is where you minimize
the error assuming you have measurement
noise in both X and Y and that's really
the crucial Point here that because of
this connection you get much more
robustness to measurement noise
okay so a summary of MP edmd we had a
four line algorithm for measure
preserving extended Dynamic mode
decomposition some advantages
we get convergence guarantees for
Spectra continuous Spectra and koopment
mode decompositions
this even comes with explicit rates for
delay in Bedding
we have long time stability and improved
qualitative Behavior we also have an
increased stability to noise for example
measurements it's also easy to use with
any existing DMD type method if you want
the code you can visit this GitHub page
here also you can look at my website
down here for further presentations
papers and code thank you very much for
your attention